she was you have a good memory for that
we're talking in March you've been in
this country for how long so you've been
here up again Washington though it
wasn't in 81 Oh - I didn't like it - I
don't know where to start with is
morning except that there's no there's
coming up some caucuses and there's some
primaries and all of them are you paying
attention to the America today no no no
so I've got any I can get ads I've can't
be a good citizen this year I can't get
a cognitive interested concrete excited
is there any clearly encourages them so
all I go around as what I try and do my
columns are didn't my little appearances
and so it is trying to get people to
treat the political leadership with the
same regarded with the same contempt
that the issue evidently has for us I
think that would be a start I really
think that last time it looked badly
like a sort of pre-arranged campaign
everything taken care of in advance the
conventions were all choreographed the
presidential debates were all fixed a
friend of Mines actually bringing a
lawsuit about that this year to prevent
the two parties from keeping out other
candidates if there are gonna be any but
this time it feels so fixed from the
very beginning has an awful feeling of
prearrangement to it I heard a rumor
that it seems to have the same effect on
the notion much of the electorate was it
has all me in fact I feel uncomfortably
as if I'm a member of a majority for
once in my life can you vote here no do
you ever intend I wouldn't know I'm
privileged to be able to do this kind of
thing to make my self felt they heard a
rumor it's not a rumor I know that
you've been you've been traveling I have
you know working you back from Cuba why
did you go to Cuban how'd you go it I
went with my family for a party for
holiday in politics I'm writing an
article about Cuba for the upcoming
Vanity Fair and I suddenly thought I
hadn't had any idea what to do brother
millennium and normally
New Year's Eve is the only night of the
year when I'm in bed by 12 I thought
that would be a bit feeble this time it
suddenly occurred to me that the
revolution took place in Cuba on New
Year's Eve if you remember
father part to all the mobsters are
there in the hotel nacional and they
think it's a fiesta going on outside the
windows but actually it's the it's the
entry of gorillas into Havana there's at
first when I got there I found out that
mr. Castro's view he always has to try
and be different than any of us until
this coming yeah he's one of those 2001
freaks say he'd be in power 40 so all
they did was mark 41 years of the Cuban
Revolution why did you seem while you're
there mr. Castro I did not he didn't
even come out and make a speech I have
seen him I've seen her speak and I've
been in the same room as him though we
haven't met well who went with you in
your family yeah the white maid who
specifically kids a wife my daughter and
my father mother-in-law how old are how
old are your children
Antonia six and then I offered to other
children live in England now well how
long were you there
about two weeks no that's not true about
eight days or did what you find there
what you see and that it's pretty bleak
now it's very plea it's very poor party
is a consequence of the collapse of the
Warsaw Pact file is the consequence of
the lack of demand for the VA it's still
the same as ever it was a colonial
economy in any remakes poisons like
sugar and tobacco but you really exports
that kind of thing tomorrow for them
isn't very great
they lost their subsidy from the Warsaw
Pact from Russia really very terrible
austerity and to make up the leeway
they've had to go for tourism and what I
would describe as the most vulgar
possible way I mean there are beaches
and hotels and resorts and so that
reserved only for non Cubans do you have
to have dollars well he turned around to
a thing but even if you arequipa and you
do have dollars there are things you're
not allowed to buy so there's a feeling
of well they call it tourists apartheid
amongst themselves and then there's a
sense of I don't know what the word
would be exactly frustration tedium
about the fact that obviously the regime
can't last forever I mean so it's a
one-man show and he's looking older and
grayer and Porsche are you Ryan he
refuses to give any idea forests in his
mind are you writing for this magazine
Vanity Fair yeah and in this cover story
of February issue
Annette Bening and
husband Warren Beatty yes I guess she's
pregnant here looks like it let's go to
music he's the great one mr. Beatty for
narrowing the gender gap let's go to
Charleston South Carolina on the
Republican line for Christopher Hitchens
good night good morning how you doing
they're winning
mr. Hitchens oh I love it when you're on
I won't miss a minute of this today
sexiest even though I'm conservative but
I wanted to know the last time I saw you
on you were pretty shaken up this had to
do with the machine
the liberal machine that went against
you for writing an article apparently on
on the impeachment on Clinton's
background and I was curious as this
changed you at all
and how to me it seems like that the
political Democratic machine works
against people that come out against
them or say some about the truth I've
always been curious about that because
to me you were really shaken up and of
course most of the country was probably
on your side I know I was so I just
wanted to see how that's changed you
well I don't know it's fortunate enough
to have missed the country on my side
not that I've really much mind whether I
do or not I think it would be a bit much
should be sound a bit self pitying to
say that was the victim of a machine
there were unpleasant things were said
about me because I had I had given the
lie to the president's lawyers and aides
in in the Senate trial of the president
they said they hadn't been spreading
rumors and calumnious and defamations
about a female witness several female
witnesses actually if you go into it I
said that I knew that they had it was as
simple as that lots of people could have
said the same and and have since I'm I'm
I'm depressed that it's gone away so
quickly I really happened that and the
this tactic of saying well let's move on
and put this all behind us and move the
country forward they're actually an
official language of amnesia people
saying it's better to forget has become
an okay thing to say trade port you're
next yes hello I'd like to start off by
saying I'm a very proud socialist and
that's quite rare in Shreveport
Louisiana what does that mean to you
well my ideas were formed as a teenager
actually watching c-span
being introduced people like Christopher
Hitchens and
Chomsky and just the idea that people
should live to you know sort of make it
make life better for other people
through you know through well you know
through their own getting together and
and working for each other is good I
want to make a point
smite mentioned earlier but George will
that the media has a left-wing bias when
I was studying journalism we there was a
sociologist named Herbert Ganz that we
studied who said that journalists in
general have a middle-of-the-road
ethnocentric bias their pro-capitalist
their pro-american and an example of
this is during the past war when the
Chinese embassy was bombed it was called
an accidental bombing and by everyone in
media and I'm not saying it wasn't an
accident but how did they know that and
why why is that sort of thing why we let
that sort of thing pass without
commenting on it mr. Chia well I caught
that but if mr. wills act actually just
as I was waiting to come in and I know
I've heard the reply that he gives quite
often which is if you poll working
members of the press in Washington and
ask how they intend to vote or how they
did vote last time you'll generally find
them pulling the Democratic lever or
voting the Democratic line and as a
matter of fact in my experience that's
true but it isn't true of the people who
earn their newspapers or their outlets
and it isn't I mean for example if you
add up another list of if you poll the
press in a different way look at the
number of editor endorsements that are
given to candidates I don't think the
Democrats ever got the majority of
newspaper endorsements television
programs to intend to make endorsements
so I don't know quite how that would
shake out the ownership of the press and
the control of it does not reflect a
liberal bias in my opinion for example I
mean take a simple example every single
newspaper has at least one heavily
advertising oriented business section
and very very few newspapers even have a
single person covering what used to be
called the labor beat of the unions and
the blue-collar world so there would be
an example of bias right there
I have found that in my excuse me in my
run-ins with the Clinton administration
that there was a tremendous some loyalty
to a certain a certain form of
democratic rule ISM in some circles of
the press I think a rather emaciated
form of it he made it made up of people
I think basically who are terrified of
the Christian Coalition and who own
matters of what they think of his
personal morality and freedom of
personal morality feel committed to what
I guess you'd have to call a liberal
line Fort Washington Maryland good
morning your honor Christopher Hitchens
Washington my question was was it really
gonna be opposed to mr. world he's gone
now but I'm sure you can help me out on
this he made the statement earlier that
during the civil rights era that most
Democrats were not as adamant for past
as a Republicans which at that time
would have been true however many of the
Democrats whether the solid south was
conservative right-wing Democrats and of
course they would not vote for civil
rights and once this thing was passed
these guys were transferred most of them
to the Republican Party transplants like
the Jesse Helms this guy from Texas
the Trent Lott and now the Republicans
take the credit for passing civil rights
when they are so adamantly against it my
second thing is when he said that his
sports player for the century would be
Babe Ruth and in my opinion not Jackie
Robinson is almost ludicrous when Jackie
Robinson had to play under circumstances
which could have caused his death
he took his fourth best sport and excels
very much in baseball he was an ideal
citizen Babe Ruth was a drunkard but
because of the time he was celebrated
for this and Jackie Robinson never got
to acclaim that he was so richly
deserved only because of his patience
and its enduring thanks caller mr.
hitchens well I seem to be nineteen
years mr. George's
crew today that was will that's what
George was following him with a shovel
as there was a pleasure atonic by the
way I can I can help out the person who
said that I disagree with what you say
but I would defend to the death your
right to say was Voltaire I was
surprised he didn't know that he was the
sort of thing I thought he would know
off the bat so let me brag and say that
I do know in that suit he did mention
Volterra did he yeah he said maybe yeah
maybe Voltaire and he's kind of one off
his mind you thought it might patron was
paid I anyway it was Voltaire all right
well as to the cause point about civil
rights it's certainly it is true that he
in the time of Franklin Roosevelt when
any attempt was made to ameliorate the
condition of first the population
suffering under segregation and official
discrimination in the South that it was
defeated by Forstner and then as the
Dixiecrats who we don't really have in
quite the same way now that Democrats
had a lock on the South that it was a
racist lock at the time when mr. Johnson
signed the Civil Rights Act he is
supposed to have said as he put down his
pant fat I think I think he was heard
saying was said to friends who've
reported that he thought that would be
the death of the Democratic Party in his
lifetime it hasn't led to that but it
did lead to to the emergence of George
Wallace and to a sort of blue collar
backlash among white turtle trading
voters now to the point about the
Republican Party my memory tells me this
that mr. Nixon looked at that phenomenon
in 68 he thought there's no reason why
those people shouldn't vote Republican
if the things properly handled we can
detach them from the Democratic Party it
was actually called the Southern
Strategy in different ways ever since
the Republicans have tried to play that
card as for sports person of the century
didn't ask but I can't imagine not
saying Muhammad Ali
go to Columbus Columbus Nebraska Oh
gentlemen good morning to you hi there
mr. Hitchens wonder if you could give us
a definition of the word miss
demeanor not misdemeanor in phrase high
crimes and misdemeanors yeah the
Democrats seem real comfortable in
retreating to his character and his
personal character now as a defense for
the president you know actions in office
can you give us a little recitation on
misdemeanor and high crimes yes I
there's an irony in your tone which I'm
not sure I'm picking up properly but
let's say that we did have to go through
a period where and for example
democratic liberal defenders of the
president were saying well what's a
little perjury when you come right down
to it what's a little obstruction of
justice you to come right down to it
what's a little you know little visit of
that I thought then and I think even
more now that what should have been
charged as the president and the
impeachment proceedings as well as the
the offenses to the law that he did
obviously and probably and provably
commit was the voice of power I wrote a
long article showing something that is
now much less controversial and it was
my first pointed out that it's a moral
certainty that he did use cruise
missiles against the Sudan on a target
there was evidently bogus in the week of
Miss lewinsky's return to the grand jury
er that he used that promiscuous element
of force presidential whim purely for
private purposes account that as abuse
of power it seemed to me that it was a
great failure on the part of the
rotation forces not to charge their and
not to not to not to remove the debate
therefore from the area of you say
misdemeanor I'll say peccadillo I'll say
it with sarcasm the the idea that these
were minor personal thoughts of the
president of the sort that we all might
have or all might commit well we don't
all commit Titanic abuses of power on
that scale and it's a pity that the
service being let drop though you may
have seen Brian in the New York Times
about three months ago now an article
full page article by James rise and
pronouncing his name correctly it's
spelled RIS am quoting all the people in
Washington in their security world in
the Defense Department in the CIA and
the State Department you had at the time
warned that that Sudan target was was
nonsense and that the cover story about
it was false the amazing thing about the
article was that having conclusively
demonstrated all that it didn't mention
what else was going on that week didn't
mention the fact the president was
struggling to boost his ratings in a
battle over impeachment so to that
extent the attempt to airbrush the
finger put it all behind us appears to
have worked but some of us are not going
to let it drop and I'm pleased to say
there's a lawsuit by the true owner of
that Factory in Sudan which didn't make
no gasping movements and the suit is
coming to trial in Washington and he's
gonna win call me Mara Columbia Missouri
gonna go ahead please hi mr. Hitchens
I've always enjoyed your work in the
nation thank you and I really enjoyed
your last very small book but very
powerful book no one left to lie to you
I thought that was very well done
yeah I'm a grad student in American
history and I just attended the American
Historical Association meeting in
Chicago and they had a session on
impeachment and Sean Wilentz was on the
panel and I'm just kind of wondering if
you might speak to this sort of public
role or well in this case political role
of historians and and also whether or
not you ever saw Jesse lanisha's sort of
counter-petition - Sean relentless
petition that said in fact what you just
brought up that he should have been
charged with abuse of power for bombing
an opportune time let me ask you about
your meeting in Chicago was the
historians was there any body on the
panel that disagree with mr. Willens
yes there was it was a lawyer and I I'm
sorry I can't remember his name there
was a lawyer who I think did testify at
the hearings
he's a came off as a very staunch
Republican I think he even said at one
point it was a very staunch Republican
but he was sort of presenting the lawyer
sort of but any hit whether the law
whether any historians that would
challenge the historians involving
tonight no no there were no historians
on the panel that really came out in
terms of challenging Shawn LaLanne
tonight and I asked about the sort of
collective amnesia among not only as a
nation at large but and in the media but
also among historians about the bombings
because I think that that is the real
issue Aaron said that it's the real
abuse of power
thank you very much Christopher Hitchens
well I mean I could only say that I
can't agree any more with that I'd add
that's one thing I mean what struck me
is interesting during the impeachment
question was that the were possibly two
points of view could take us to whether
the president's breaking of actually
existing American law did as they used
to say rise to the level of the
impeachable but I used to wonder well
what happens if the law just takes its
course
I mean he's committed perjury so it can
be indicted for it or has committed
contempt of court the thing got out of
sync I it's never been clear to me why
justice Susan Webber Wright took as long
as she did to conclude that her court
had been outraged and decide the
president for contempt she didn't do it
till after the impeachment hearings were
over also alas it wasn't until after the
impeachment hearings were over that the
network's saw fit to run the I thought
entirely convincing account by mrs.
Juanita Broderick of home being raped by
the president not the only woman who can
plausibly make this charge by the way
that's another thing which makes people
go all cold and withdrawn if you bring
it up they think well wait a minute it
it's not that it isn't true or is true
that there's the rapists in the Oval
Office it can't be true because what
would that make us and where would it
leave us but they have no answer to the
charge as brought excuse me not has
brought that house made by Miss Project
so they only and the president refuses
to comment on it he won't even deny it
which is something I think I would want
to improve on if I was in his position
tomorrow let me get this listing silence
descends on the whole culture about
about the possibility that the guy's a
monster tomorrow live at 2 o'clock East
Coast time the Republicans debate in Des
Moines live on this network for an hour
and a half
on Monday this morning on Monday 10
o'clock at night will re-air the MSNBC
debate that they're covering out of Iowa
with Al Gore and Bill Bradley it'll go
live at 6 o'clock that night and we're
covering union-leader published or Nike
Loubs memorial service today in
Manchester it'll be on sometime over the
weekend Petersburg Virginia on the
democratic line go ahead please East
statement but I'm a six to one your
african-american and I fail to
understand why a lot of Americans don't
look at an issue first as to whether
it's right or wrong
forget about politics forget about a
business and I guess what I'm saying is
with Clinton impeachment everybody knows
that has been following the thing that
Richard Matt escaped was a big person
behind it everybody knew that John Gotti
was a big mouth everybody that the Frank
Sinatra was involved with the mob young
people and I guess in their twenties and
thirties and forties that are reading
history knew that who was supposed to
kill Martin Luther King John F Kennedy
Bobby Kennedy Malcolm X did not kill
them they knew that there were others
are killed and whether it was a vast
conspiracy or not but they don't
understand why there's so much crime in
the streets why young sure not obeying
their parents why be rebelling against
at first they seem to think the
teenagers don't watch what you do more
than what you say thanks I better take
it as a comment let's go to Chicago well
on the air yes mr. Hitchens I just
wanted to tell you my two favorite
speakers in the whole world are Bill
Buckley and you hey I haven't decided
which one of you should have beaten
Oxford Mississippi the other day away
you know I went to I went to help the
record the last firing line show
I sure wish I would I heard that I work
a lot and I don't pay attention and I
miss a lot of good stuff Connor why
why are those two people are that your
favorite speakers they're the most
articulate and intelligent I wish I had
the cognitive ability to communicate an
idea the way you guys can I was just
curious if you don't mind my asking mr.
Hitchens how old are you I was fifty
last year so I'll be 51 this year and
why we're in April and why do you think
you were the last they did on the you're
on the last show environment it was
known I thought I mean they there was a
four side debate in Oxford Mississippi
they wanted to had to wrap it up and
they chose me and robert kuttner and I'm
gonna forget his name but uh he's did a
while blanking on it he's the mayor of
Dallas Texas
he's a very impressive guy got to be
hearing more of him and his name was Ron
something I'm terribly sorry
I should know myself because you've been
on this program up here he's my stylist
will help us on this and Seattle you're
next
hi how are you fine welcome uh yeah I
had a question for your guests I was up
early this morning so I heard him speak
about the bombing we Dan with President
Bush and the what was of the savings of
Loan scandal mm-hmm now during that time
that's when the bush initiated the what
was at the the other war and nobody
likes to talk about well and it just
seems to me that nobody ever talks about
what was going on with the Savings and
Loan scandal when that war got initiated
how it kind of fell back on the back
burner intentions well it was a matter
of fact I don't seem to the savings and
then scandal was confronted about well
mr. senator I should say McCain to this
day has difficulty with the subject
winning comes up even though he was not
the most prominent of the five senators
who were recipients of the tremendous
largesse of Charles Keating of the
Lincoln Savings a now it's true that one
of President Bush's sons I believe Neil
Bush
who appears not to be governing even a
single state of the union at the moment
I mean what he what became said was
absolved in her inner servants and then
but I don't think that the strongest
critic of the Bush family or of the Gulf
Gulf War and I would want to be numbered
he'd both first groups I would say that
mr. Bush was able to start that war to
distract attention from his sons
business dealings you might think what
mr. Clinton did to sit down to Khartoum
in August of last year excuse me the
year before we must now say it has no
precedent the the worst you could say
about Ronald Reagan's invasion of
Grenada was that it was a distraction
from the humiliation that the United
States Marines have just before suffered
in Beirut you could say that there was
an element of contrivance in the in the
operation but you could not say that
roll Reagan did it because he was having
matrimonial difficulties with Nancy you
couldn't say it was done entirely to
save his own hide and for completely
private purposes you can and in my
opinion must reach that conclusion about
the bombing of Sudan it is unprecedented
as an as a exploitation promiscuous
private selfish exploitation of power
per sitting president the magazine that
you write for Vanity Fair has this cover
story on Warren Beatty and Annette
Bening his wife a reason I show you this
photograph is a couple of months ago
they this man was on the news constantly
mm-hmm what happened well what happened
was that Arianna Stinson applause
Huffington as she now is Huffington
indeed had the idea she's one of the
authors of this idea of compassionate
conservatism she's moved a little more
to the liberal side I think since
initiating that had the idea that there
must be someone just to run as a
candidate who would stick up for the
poor and the downtrodden and she
proposed Warren Beatty I don't think
asking him in advance I may be wrong
about that and quite a lot of people
immediately got excited because he'd
worked for Gary Hart he'd been around
you know the fundraising circuit he's
made some good political movies and it
was a buzz for about two weeks but it
seems to be over
Lana you're next for Christopher
Hitchens let's go ahead please good
morning morning you know one thing is
very very obvious of most people in
America we look at someone like
Christopher Hitchens and all of them
very jealous people of Bill Clinton and
they just go home and hone and think we
can see through god Bless You mr.
Hitchens because we understand we look
much much rather have someone like Bill
Clinton you oh you can do it back right
well not so one second
you must indict the Joint Chiefs of
staff's Secretary of Defense you
understand
to make your theory complete these guys
got their own criminal career on the
line so you must do that also with Joe
you know with your theory the next thing
you have to remember before Bill Clinton
the president there was $500,000 the
saving one that was stolen from the
people now he wasn't president being the
people who pay that money to people to
pay income tax the poise of people okay
yes
now you know who you know about
whitewater held me who stole that money
okay also an you tell me the missile
that was sold as for the Iranian people
can you tell me that some of those
missile what news on people but we we
lift up the people that you are want to
up and you are take down a man it
doesn't have a connection that done it
all on his own Bill Clinton doesn't have
a topper senator that this father like
Al Gore what president like his father
George Bush but neither one of y'all I
haven't met yet not one person that I've
been able to see in America that can
turn to Bill Clinton for the facts and
what do you know that what you've done
there are taking a man and use the power
of the law and the media
and your feet'll isn't a lie about a
secular sense that each that you can't
get pregnant on thanks go let's go the
phone was beginning to fade on us and
there were I think he was getting
getting towards the end of his yeah
Federation well on the point about the
Joint Chiefs I mean what the caller
correctly says is that if that was an
abuse of power the bombing of Sudan then
the judge who saw as in Dodgeville so to
speak for does the president well one
reason why I think my theory about this
abuse of power is correct is that the
majority of the Joint Chiefs were not
informed or consulted about that
decision that's one of the things that
makes it unprecedented that was the
striking thing about the New York Times
article search which I can refer you was
the number of people who had been
service to be presidential II kept out
of the loop so to speak who would
normally be in it on it on a decision of
this kind and of those who were brought
in most counseled against it partly
because the target was very likely to be
what it has since proved to be namely a
bogus target it's not Journal I'm sorry
I'm sorry
well I don't know if I would seem to
vasive if I if I hadn't answered all of
the rest I mean quite clearly we have a
partisan of the president's here I I
would just say you're quite right in
saying that he made it so to speak on
his own didn't come from privilege into
politics and that and you're so right in
saying has an impressive command of
detail and data that's why it's so
surprising and so depressing but he lies
so much and so often so still why he
can't be believed whereas he often has
done he and his subordinates claimed not
to remember things that really must have
stuck in their memory let me ask you now
mister master of detail mister briefing
book has no right to take refuge in the
I can't record offensive I just want you
to get very quick reactions to these
four names I'm gonna give you George W
Bush mediocre nonentity I think John
McCain overrated blowhard Bill Bradley a
man who boasts of having Henry Kissinger
as his foreign policy adviser that does
it for me
Al Gore a pathetic doormat of a man
who's been you know subjected himself to
eight years of humiliation now and must
wish every day that he'd had the nerve
against George Bush in in 92 because he
must relive his decision not to do that
every day
couple quick and kind of you kind of a
shred of self-respect left to a Buchanan
well public only represents a tradition
that I abominate the tradition of father
Coughlin and Franco and Joseph McCarthy
and all the other people who he admires
and wishes to us to resuscitate Athens
Tennessee on a Republican line for
Christopher Hitchens go ahead please
yes mr. hedges I was watching uh I guess
well it used to be the MacNeil Leonard
murder you're about couple of three
weeks ago and they were interviewing
people in Moscow on the street and most
of the people that they interviewed had
they believe that Russia had bombed
their own apartment buildings and I've
never heard this anywhere else on the
news in anywhere else about it's being
talked about and it's a reverse Bill
Clinton instead of bomb on a foreign
country they bombed their own country
what do you think well I think the
Russian treatment of Chechnya is now and
has been for a very long time atrocious
goes back a long way you can read you
can read the works of count Tolstoy
actually who was a serving officer in
the Caucasus in the in the bad old days
of Saracen who decided it's a wonderful
novel called [ __ ] Murat that they
attempt to try and crush these Muslim
Caucasian populations was doomed to
failure and would also corrupt
Russia itself I think he was right on
both counts there are some pretty gaunt
figures among the Chechen leadership I
understand but it's not impossible that
they would have after the near
destruction of their capital city the
last time around who have opted for
revenge of that kind but it's not nor is
it impossible as you as you suggest that
some element of the Russian mafia or
some actual professor close to the steel
since police are at the station is a
provocation the National Journal has its
biennial salary survey of Washington
lobbyist Gene Upshaw the National
Football League Players Association is
number winding scene there on the car
and he leads the magazine money players
they call it then they show over here
the list of the top lobbyists in
addition to mr. Upshaw who was number
one and makes out funded in a minute
it's over a million dollars let the good
times roll national Journal's first
salary survey ran in 1990 they say here
and here's the list and they show the
comparisons Jack Valenti
million it was 672 and 89 Robert vaguely
for 74 and 80 90 is the American
Insurance Association is up to 925
Donald Ogilvy from 450 to 635 American
Bankers Association John damn guard 407
and 89 future Industries Association
he's up to 485 goes on Heather Ruth's at
2:30 up to 612 she's the bond market
Association I'm gonna ask about this in
a moment Greenville South Carolina go
ahead please oh what a thrill Brian
corner if you can hear me we can um I've
learned that the reason some of us
sounds so pathetic is we've been on mute
and we've lost track of your
conversation and I'm apologizing last
time I called you I sounded like a
schizophrenic terrorist I think I'm the
first one who mentioned y2k to you and
you nor you just had any clue at the
time but what I'd like to bring to your
attention this morning is the Washington
Times article the headline is Jane Fonda
becomes a born-again Christian and I'm
stunned that no one else has mentioned
this this morning in the light of the
fact that she and her wonderful husband
Ted Turner who I admire greatly has made
some pretty disparaging remarks about
Christians and has kind of taken it on
the chin but according to this article
one of her longtime critics calls it a
conversate excuse me a conversion right
up there with Saul of Tarsus and I
wonder if the Christians who are paying
attention might pray for Jane thank you
for everything Brian I love your show
thanks and by the way you must have been
listening earlier because we talked
about this and of course when I need it
I can't find it it's somewhere on this
watch this morning
I couldn't believe it was the only paper
I was seeing it in well it can't appears
to be an element in the separation that
between if you have separated between no
her separation from mr. Turner
it came from here it's an old story
let's say this what's today is the 14th
it started on January the 6th on a on a
calm a world daily
worldnetdaily calm Joseph Farah was
responsible for the story and the story
in The Washington Times basically
parrots what he said and it says fun two
becomes born-again Christian and she
goes to the to the Church of among other
things of her chauffeur down in Atlanta
yes and what would you like to are you a
Christian I'm not
what are those a member of any Church
identically I don't think that this any
supernatural guidance and here's the
article by the way and during my
presence here is some is attributable to
any form of divine intervention what did
you make of this tour I thought it was a
sad little story why well someone's
getting a bit old a bit silly and
perhaps lacking for attention it's and
who I would thought of being content
with being born once which is all that
and fact she's ever gonna be or any of
us are only gonna be born once so the
oldest born-again stuff just gets me
down gives me pain says in this article
I'm extremely impressed with the
genuineness and the sincerity and her
search for spirituality and wholeness
the Reverend Gerald derly pastor of the
Providence Missionary Baptist Church in
Atlanta where mr. Fonda has attended
services till the Atlanta
journal-constitution I think she's found
a certain sense of peace among people
who found peace with Christianity so
hard to object chosen you know what I I
think what I don't like well there's a
lot of it I don't like as well as
finding it totally intellectually and
morally unconvincing is that this is the
form that they believe modesty should
take is going around all the time about
how you found God and how God has a
special purpose for you this is this is
construed as humility it seems to me the
height of a modesty to say that you've
been chosen in this way or selected all
that you could possibly know that you
had been it's arrogant and conceited and
eager to stay wider veil New York on the
democratic
from Christopher Hitchens go ahead
please yes hi I just wanted to make a
comment and then I asked mr. Hitchens a
question my comment is I keep hearing
about this mother dying on the rap that
brought the boy over from Cuba which is
a tragedy in itself but as they are
considered what if the mothers had
survived and the child had died women
are charged in this country all the time
with endangerment of their children
they're in charge with murder I would
just like to ask mr. Hitchens what his
feeling is on as far as the boy going
back in Cuba Thanks well it's a
no-brainer if his father and his
grandfather want him and of course it
would be a no-brainer if there was any
other country but Cuba but whenever the
name Cuba's mentioned large numbers of
people in the American political
stablishment consider themselves to have
been given permission to take complete
leave of their senses and you can see it
time and time and time again the fact is
though I made an interesting discovery
when I was in Cuba the United States
Embassy there where it says there isn't
an embassy of course it's an interest
section so-called because there are no
formal relations Institute a lottery of
20,000 visas last year which is the
legally agreed number with the Cuban
government and this lottery of 20,000
visas was advertised in the Cuban
Communist Party pressed in fact the form
that you need to apply was printed in
the Communist paper it's called grandma
they got more than half a million people
applying for these 20,000 slots and you
had to be I believe over 18 and under 50
and only one person per family could
apply so that's a lot of people trying
to leave now none of this would be
necessary no this awful pressure would
have built up I think if the
commonsensical
policy of lifting the embargo was ended
and if normal relations
existed between this country and what is
in effect its closest neighbor after
Mexico and Canada and it's the failure
of any politician to have the nerve to
say that's what we should do there leads
to women I can't get certain motives or
how miserable she was or how desperate
but women being put in that false
position with their children - former
presidential candidate John Anderson in
30 minutes on this program
Cleveland Ohio for Christopher Hitchins
good morning good morning Brian great
program Christopher my wife purchased
your book no one left the light too good
for me for Christmas once I started
reading it I couldn't put it down
great book thank you I wish more people
that have called in this morning would
read your books so they could understand
more about our good president Bill and
Hillary my other question is are you
working on another book possibly Thanks
well I'm actually working on updating
that one which contains I hope you
haven't spotted them yet
some were lamentable mistakes but
probably the result of haste so I want
to comb them out
and they want to update it a bit for
some developments in the struggle to
impeach the president that have occurred
since and then I want to perhaps add a
chapter or two about his lovely wife and
her feeling that just as presidential
therapy worked so well for her husband
senatorial therapy might have a chance
of working for her how do you feel that
most of calls that have congratulated
you and thanked you and said they bought
your Booker Republicans how do you feel
that that your book might have sold
because conservatives or Republicans
bought it in a society that is market
oriented sure it's highly happy with
that doesn't bad no no sir
not in the least in fact more power to
their their elbow and their purchasing
power to I watch a lot of conservative
radio shows at that time and TV shows -
I got some quite critical reviews in the
conservative press but on the whole I
got some ludicrously unfair and
ill-tempered ones in the what you might
call the liberal press as well it seemed
to me that the okay though they didn't
charge abuse of power as they should
have done that the speeches and the
reasonings offered particularly by Mays
Hutchinson Lindsey Graham and was my two
favorite of the house managers work just
absolutely convincing her that it was it
is - the lasting disgrace of the
Democratic Party that not one of its
legislators was willing to break ranks
and say what they knew well I'll say
what they knew act as if what they said
they knew to be true
mattered and was it was a matter of
principle
it wasn't a disgraced in such a man
should be President Indianapolis go
ahead please
hi there how are you welcome sir hey I
have a question for mr. Hitchens am I
very far wrong when I say that the
enemies of Pat Buchanan have supplanted
the word isolationism or the word
patriotism thank you I've supplanted the
word isolationism for I think I'm not
certain out follow the grammar of the
question sir he's not still there let me
ask you about this this National Journal
survey of the top 50 highest paid trade
association yes I saw this yesterday of
the post
yes Gene Upshaw is a million eighty year
Frank Zarb I who used to I think being
the next administration runs the
National Association here these 1.5
million a year Ron Ziegler he's no
longer in this job but as the National
Association of chain drugstores he was
getting 1.4 million once when to speak
of his convention in Palm Beach we have
a great time they paid you yeah no bad
the other jack valenti 1 million Carroll
Campbell former congressman $891,000 he
was down I read that he wasn't he was as
high as he had be you know he's getting
the same money but he's not right he
never want people are getting more money
than him then you have Carroll camels I
was mentioning they do for the money
isn't that what you want to ask I got
some more heroin tell the audience about
Frank Frank off on this list at 727 or
52,000 he's the American Gaming
Association former congressman Willis
gradison 737,000 the health insurance
Association of America former
Congressman hen stood more American
forest and paper Association 700 3,000
former congressman Dan mica credit union
national national association 688
thousand and then a little bit lower is
Al Gore's former chief of staff Roy Neal
United States telecom Association 511
thousand yes well I would like to know
what they do for the money and what they
do with it once they've got it I don't
know what it can be like for the people
who are just getting by and maybe
working more than one job to see that
those sorts of salaries being paid for
people who are just basically in
Washington to to blow their
organizations and horns I mean how tough
is it to be one zebra in that position
it's nice that he was to me in a couple
of other well wayne lapierre
nra 249,000 Sarah Brady handgun control
238,000 new Lemon Valley Nevada go ahead
please
good morning hi three things I was very
amused at your quick wit and you
described the rogue's gallery of
candidates just now oh thank you is the
merest abuse I mean I'm sorry I would
try be with you next time
do you think I think it's deliciously
ironic that you've been adopted as a
darling of the right wing and you're a
leftist like me and the third thing well
the right wing was time to rise on the
important matter of principle which this
issue about about Sudan didn't wasn't
Afghanistan also bombed at the same time
in response to the bombings of our
embassies Afghanistan was bombed for
legitimate reasons how does that affect
your theory that the whole thing was
used as a cover for the Monica Lewinsky
I think Afghanistan was legitimate i
that leads me to believe that Sudan
simply mistake only Afghanistan also
because as far as I know there were no
diplomatic relations with the Afghan
government that may be wrong there there
are with Sudan and it it's believed that
mr. Osama bin Laden is there or was
there there actually first I remember at
least one of the cruise missiles hit
Pakistan which are just not long before
that gone nuclear so I'm not sure that
really the of the prudence of the
operation it doesn't affect my theory at
all drayton Marilyn good morning yeah
Bravo Zulu to you by here the master
this for man wow that's that's an old
navy term you wouldn't you wouldn't
probably know that except your father's
name
yeah it wasn't very much so say no
Braavosi I've just spent a week reading
and reviewing all the novels of Patrick
O'Brian if you tried them by the way the
ones the deceased Patrick over 800 yeah
yes sir
mr. Hitchens I'm not sure that you're
considered universally the darling
of the conservatives in this country but
I did admire your ability to speak out
on something that so obviously was wrong
and that's my point mr. will was on
earlier and yourself are pretty much to
be considered at opposite ends of the
spectrum but the striking point is how
obtuse a bend was made in that spectrum
to meet in the middle at both ends in
recognizing that Bill Clinton and and
his minions were so adamantly wrong in
the way they handled the process after
he was flagrantly caught out
I'd like your comments on that and and
the with regard to how the spectrum was
bare to recognize that why they why the
middle ground of that spectrum is pretty
much turned a blind eye towards the
process intentions well there were
people on the left in in 1992 who were
actually almost the only ones to point
out that there was something funny by
the way attention did business in his
home state welcome so there's some
affair by the way he raised money there
was something a bit iffy about his
attitude to women and so on I mean I'm
making this point myself would not alone
Alexander Coburn or serve the nation
Ralph Nader and Jerry Brown both brought
it up during the debates if you remember
Clinton was very annoyed at being asked
these questions about his wife's
business activities by Governor Brown of
California so at that time the right
wing wasn't doing anything about it
because well what do you know the white
water business is a savings and loan
business for one thing well the Madison
Bank as a service and their business
didn't if you want to bring up savings
in learning the Republicans that year
it's easy to see why nor do they want to
bring up campaign finance misbehavior
for obvious reasons on topics like that
there's very often a kind of mutual
assured destruction between the parties
a consensus not to bring these things up
wouldn't anyway have been the
Republicans raising topics like that
against attention so for a while that
there was a was rather a weird eerie
projection of Clinton and he was
attacked only from the left
then force that you could I suppose
described as the Christian or moralistic
right became more fully informed of the
thing and more seized of the idea that
Clinton was a rat bag and a draft dodger
and a teacher and so on and they began
to make the running and I'm afraid that
that had the paradoxical effect of
scaring a lot of liberals who should
have known better and to say well we
can't be on the same side as these
right-wing rednecks some improvement did
indeed make hysterical accusations such
as the Clinton admitted Vince Foster and
all kinds of absurd things like that
which one is suited his Booker and eats
you well because it then became possible
to paint people say such as myself who
really did think the president was a
crook and a psycho as wackos and
eccentrics and so forth so they it was a
very low level of debate all the way
through that's but that's a partial
guide to why it stayed low because so
some people know that I have to use
words some enjoyed your
characterizations of people running I
want to try some more with you just to
get this is quick Donald Trump please
well he's managed to cover 90% of his
head with thirty percent of his hair
Jesse that's the chief and I'm sorry to
see he's lost the Slovene supermodel
there she was she was some absolutely
artful newmars upset about that today
rights but don't mention him Jesse
Ventura well I'd like to I like what he
said about religion I thought that was
courageous and I was sorry to see him
trying to back away from it
Ryan I know no bad things about him he
doesn't he does somehow find it hard to
shake the impression of being a town
then Ross Perot the guy with us of
megalo you noticed that McCain wants to
call the man in charge of reform as are
you noticed that this morning I wish we
could bearish the words are from from
discourse we don't really need her every
autocrat but um it always seems to me
that poor ojeda's are complex steve
forbes smart guy smart guy and
thoughtful and running uh she could
interesting campaign Burlington New
Jersey good morning yes I find it
wonderfully ironic said mr. Hitchens at
mama
Joseph McCarthy certainly doesn't
abominate his tactics as they were used
in the last couple of years to take a
little bit of truth a swirl of innuendo
many accusations and believe a Juanita
Broderick for example or any other such
story but regarding Lindsey Graham and a
sahaja yoga Ling miss Broderick Alya
what what what would you do what if you
if you do you have more you have more
nerve than them I don't have more nerve
than the president you didn't discuss
their accusation I don't call her a liar
but why do you believe her well because
I think her story has been extensively
checked out and found to ring true
wherever its tested and because I know
of no motive for a rape yes I know
mantra where could I know of no I know
of no mo if she could possibly have
well let me just - well you might and I
just say one thing I have very little
time regarding Lindsey Graham and ASA
Hutchinson the difference between those
two people is mr. Hutchinson recognized
the failure of that committee which will
be their legacy to actually investigate
the matter before they rush through
impeachment articles and when it got to
the Senate mr. HS ASA Hutchinson was not
one of those so-called house managers
whining all over the media that how can
we possibly not let us call witnesses
how can we prove our case well mr.
Hutchinson knew the irony of that
statement and the exposure that mr.
Graham was was making of himself as
being a member of a committee had failed
to prove what they later wanted the
Senate to convict on thank you well I
think I votes he failed to find his
common ground button I think we've said
enough about the impeachment let me keep
my if he's charged me directly on this
broad rate I'm willing to if we have
time say why I think she's channel true
I think you said it I mean I think he
gave well I know the reasons there are
no negative there's no reason to think
that she could have or would have wanted
to make it up or had any inducement she
was so sorry that for a very long time
she was hoping not to be made public
which
was something in the end she was unable
to avoid she already told her own story
when it was in danger of being told or
had been partly told by it by others for
for her she was extremely reluctant to
come forward but every element of the
story that Lisa Myers and the reporters
on the thing could check proved out and
when the president was asked where he'd
been that day and he was after all
Attorney General of the state of
Arkansas he wouldn't help furnish an
alibi and he has refused steadfastly to
comment on even when practically begged
by Sundance and he said well sir where'd
she even deny it now if I was a man
accused of rape by woman of character
and reputation limas project I'd want to
do a lot better than saying absolutely
nothing oh I think that women who make
false accusations of this kind should be
prosecuted with extreme severity by the
way Oakland New Jersey hello hi kudos to
c-span for the fine service they provide
and my admiration even though I am a
conservative for mr. Hudson's clarity of
language on one thing he said earlier
which bugs the heck out of me is the use
of a certain phrase that was used
throughout the impeachment and in my way
of thinking whenever you commit a crime
you usually lower yourself to the level
of a crime don't you find it irritating
to use the phrase rise to the level of a
crime I think that use of the phrase is
what made the difference between
impeachment and not impeachment Thanks
it's true because they were saying at
the same time that it would be lowering
the bar for impeachment because it
didn't rise to the level of and I found
that I kept her to work out which
excuses being made in in what order the
fact of the matter is though that the
bar for impeachment has now been raised
almost out of reach the ideal position
to be and I think would be the next
corrupt Republican president because I
don't either be anyway they could get
you you'd have a if Wall Street was
doing all right you'd have all you'd
have a wall street defense if you were
lucky enough to be writing well in the
polls you'd be granted an opinion poll
defense if you were clever enough to
include among your crimes abuse of or
harassment of women you'd have a privacy
defense on the grounds no one wants to
know what goes on
private life and the Democrats wouldn't
be able to try and impeach you because
that would be partisan and you can't
have partisan an impeachment so you'd
have to be impeached by members of your
own party early well that would give you
I think pretty enough trying to run out
the clock with no so that's the pins and
legacy to the next Republican you might
want to take it fun to show this Seymour
Indiana you're next
you know Seymour Indiana you're on the
air yes I have a comment to make I think
the Republican Party screwed up when
they did not nominate Pat Buchanan cuz I
think he was the medic could have beat
their printed thanks well with stood
mizzen running this time so that would
have been a waste of mr. Buchanan's
efforts let me read you something it's
in The Washington Times it's in the
inside the beltway column by John
McCaslin and I want to find out how much
I just want you to put this in
perspective it takes a little bit to
read it veteran newsman and former CBS
anchor Walter Cronkite wrote two years
ago that he did his best to report on
the issues of the day and as objective a
manner as possible
end quote when I had my own strong
opinions as I often did I tried not to
communicate them to my audience unquote
but then the circumstances were
different he noted that mr. Cronkite
found himself quoted in a position to
speak in my mind it so happened that
among his first task was to nail the
Christian Coalition of the cross quote
with the Christian Coalition I have a
problem mr. Cronkite wrote in 1998
labeling the two million member
coalition a well-funded genuinely
radical movement that possesses a
militant ideology now this year 2000 mr.
Cronkite has taken up the cause of world
governance that's in quotes desiring
that the United Nations do the governing
quote the United Nations formed in 1945
to deal with global problems has had
many successes he writes on behalf of
the world Federalist associations
campaign for global change still he says
it can do much more quote if you're
thinking you're already involved in
enough causes think about this until we
have effective international law to
forge genuine enforceable international
solutions many of the most vexing
problems we face will continue to defy
remedy which bit would you like me just
love first of all are you and are you in
agreement with that with the last bit
yeah well I certainly think that the
the framework of international law needs
to be strengthened then I'm I'm pleased
with a couple of things that have
happened recently in particular the the
discovery that dictators are not above
the law in other words the I take the
view of the Spanish Court the General
Pinochet should have been extradited and
I think that there was a major step
forward to show that the law applies to
all people crimes of murder kidnapping
and torture and so on don't yet have any
immunity with that level and I'm pleased
by the way also that certain
non-government organizations have been
able to intervene in countries like
Rwanda and Kosovo s or where the rest of
the international community had failed
and sort of provide something like the
simulacrum of the international
community until more can be done
giant anatomists honest to find that mr.
so unhorsed me if I say that mr.
Cronkite had begun by saying he always
used to keep his opinions to himself
that's not how I remember at all I
remember him making a huge fuss about
the war in Vietnam for example on the
air it seems to have changed locals
minds at the time ran out of time and
John Anderson by the way will be with us
in 15 minutes is president of the world
Federalist Association and quick I got
one more call but I want to ask you
about John Anderson what would you say
about him you might meet him by the way
on your way out he's teething I ran
against contra he's the guy that ran in
1976 and got I think a 76 5 point he's
also the guy who once proposed there
should be a constitutional amendment
saying the United States should be a
Christian society so if I do get the
chance to run into me in the doorway I
wonder why was 1980 well I'll see what
was running through his mind when he
thought from that 1980 almost 180
because it was the earth for a Reagan's
election it was Ronald Reagan and Jimmy
Carter esto next to last call from Port
Allegheny Pennsylvania go ahead please
good morning hi there thank you for this
opportunity to speak with you welcome
Christopher I enjoyed what you said
about the being born again and the
modesty and how the two don't coincide
I just wanted to ask you your opinion on
Susan Faludi and her two books backlash
and her new & Stift if you've read them
and how you view those thank you I have
not read them I'm sure be sorry so yeah
I think I probably better know it I have
read work like other than half lines I
read that she was about there was a
brilliant article about some about
pornography in The New Yorker which I
believe forms part of the new book which
has the rather risky title of stiffed
search that still I suppose I I could
say that where I was familiar with her
work I've enjoyed it
Christopher Hitchens thank you for
joining us what was the pleasure we're
gonna have to unhook you're gonna stay
here and continue chatting with the
audience and please come back it takes
nothing anytime the Cuba situation is
gonna be written about it and what
Vanity Fair the coming one yeah the
February ones out right now and it'll be
much okay.thank what's this space thanks
for coming we have about an hour to go
on this Friday Washington journal and
John Anderson will be with us at 15
after the hour but downstairs in our
control room is Christopher long who is